joining us now is the pride of Lehi the
pride of Canton Ohio and the Portland
Trail Blazers guard CJ McCollum his
podcast the pull-up podcast alongside
Jordan Schultz it's available on Apple
podcast Spotify and whoever else you can
get your podcast
good morning CJ how are you good morning
I'm doing well how you doing I'm good
what did you think of your Cleveland
Browns draft I liked it I liked it I
think I'll give it a b b- right now
until the players actually step on the
field but i like the protection for
baker
I love the safety at elections we also
grabbed a tight end I believe so I'm
looking forward to just saying hi
everybody pants out and hopefully you
can sneak a wild-card appearance thank
you when the Browns lose how does that
affect you my mood changes my mood
definitely changes it's similar to how
you feel when it rains outside I come a
little bit down on yourself or your
little grouchy and it's just hard to go
on until the next one yeah but it always
rains in Portland so you're always
grouchy we get sunny days here in this
time of year we get 80 and sunny 75 and
sunny like San Diego how's the court at
home how much whooping are you doing I
haven't shot a basketball over a month
looping I don't have a court
I got a nice nice home here beautiful
landscaping and I'm you know in distance
it drives for the price facilities also
like my 24-hour access would always be
now it's been to live a good solution to
homework without a basketball wait I'm
I'm shooting more hoops than you are
right now absolutely if you've shot in
the last month you definitely probably
have a better jump I shot 30 30 minutes
ago CJ I'm I'm pumping out jumpers I
mean I can send you video just so you
can see what the form looks like they
call me you know the older klay Thompson
I'm sure you probably have a beautiful
offense couldn't a said shot
Wow yuck do you have a neighbor close by
you as a basketball who there's a few
basketball courts around me but I just
don't feel right
you know especially since we're
practicing social I think you just let
the neighbors know I'm gonna come over
and I'm gonna work out for an hour if
everybody could stay in the house then
that that way you practice safe
distancing there I actually just got the
UH garage code to one of my teammates
that used to live on I'm gonna start
going to work on his house and he's in
Miami
what kind of playing shape are you in
how much time are you gonna I'm worried
about you CJ I'm worried about the
jumper you know you have a gut no no
wait close to my playing body fat I'm
still working out like I left at the
dare cardio occasionally popping fences
and checking out the turf at certain
places but you know hasn't gotten
chi-lites operations just yet so I'm
gonna do it yeah the freedom the freedom
I hear in order to run around and get
some fresh air he's CJ McCollum the
Blazers guard his podcast to pull up
podcast the alongside Jordan Schultz
available an apple podcast Spotify and
everywhere else you can get your podcast
what have you been thinking what's your
reaction to the Jordan documentary on
the Bulls documentary I loved it I
really enjoyed the stories I wanted to
share a lot of the small details that
you you know maybe are familiar with
heard our member are being brought to
the forefront I think it was going to
really just focus on Danish Robin for a
little bit because he's such a
non-treatment
figure and the guy was polarizing the
game of basketball and she became our
sambar so I really enjoyed it I can't
wait to see the rest of it I wish it was
longer than say after senator wish I
could watch all of it you know in one
day but you know it made sense oh is
that much more fun can you compare
LeBron to Michael Jordan
you can but you can't because the their
approaches are different
there's obviously you know one six eight
to fifty to sixty the air is a different
Jordan Jordan is more against the twenty
people say it all the time Jordan's
mentality was born like Kobe the bronze
Matata was more like magic point forward
she makes the game more fun for
everybody
Kobe and Jordan were more assassins in
terms of scoring and that approach but
you can compare their greatness I think
that's something you can compare the
other type of out of the game are
they're both global figures one things
for starting we've all kind of patterned
our games after Jordan especially
earlier with people's band the tongue
out the fatal is I think they're both
elite in their own writing and both will
be considered you know many people's
mount Rushmore's how about we pick teams
and you get the first pick you can have
Jordan or you can have LeBron who do you
want is your teammate
well gyro yeah you know this is just
ninety one is this crime is this twenty
eight thirty two-year-old like what are
we doing both players are thirty both
players are thirty yeah I mean Aki I
think I would slip of corn and hopefully
the coin lands off advertisers right so
you're taking Mike okay I mean Mike's
probably Mike right now because the
Bronston still not finished the bronze
they've got a lot of a lot of left in
the tank you can still get more
championships morally please you can
solidify his legacy as the all-time
leading scorer at all-time leading this
or second just talking about the second
stop Genesis can you imagine anybody
like Dennis Rodman in the league no no I
don't think so with the mentality the
ability to go get three rebounds I mean
he's he's the only selfless guy I know
right now that you know would go play a
whole gaming not care if they ran a play
for I think three mom's another guy who
wouldn't care if they ran a play for him
but there are a lot of guys out there
that would be selfless would rebound car
one through five and you know make the
headlines that
night you know for having orange or
people in the club with carbonate
lecture or Madonna open China yeah he's
the only guy I know that we had exist
and that's where vacation abilities
gonna be granted one but I and having
been there during those championship
runs and you'd see Rodman come down the
hall and he might have makeup on he
might have a dress on like and you got
to the point where you just said Oh
Dennis is here it would become so normal
to see Dennis but he was so abnormal
when you consider the way the league was
and he didn't care what you thought of
him because he was gonna go out and get
you whatever you wanted and he was gonna
play defense he'd get to the free-throw
line CJ and he didn't even want to be at
the free-throw line
he didn't care if he made his
free-throws he wanted nothing to do with
scoring which is it's amazing you're
right there's nobody like that yeah it's
amazing the impact he was able to have
won the game like you said before coming
in and dresses to makeup
he was an iconic digger I remember
though the wedding he did in New York
where he wore the dress yeah he had
essentially a parade he's unlike
anything we've ever seen unlike thinking
we would ever see I think that just kind
of shows you know the impact he had for
the bull to take a chance on a guy like
Dennis Rodman after it was basically you
know thrown out going out to de-stress
to take that chance in the winds we
Championships Phil Jackson the bull they
deserve a lot of credit because not a
lot of teams and coach it was they
wanted to take on a player like there's
at that point who's the guest you want
on your podcast you haven't spoken to I
would say while we're in the
conversation and having it I would go
Michael Julie no you can't get Michael
you can't you can't get a basketball
player nope any any profession any field
yeah I'd go Michelle Obama okay well if
I said you could interview Michelle
Obama or Michael Jordan oh man
that's cuz I probably go Michelle
because we haven't heard a lot of behind
missing stories this onto a book and
some of the stuff she's come out and
said I know a lot about Michael I know
I'm going so I probably won't rather
have a conversation with Michelle just
to learn more about it was like the
first lady Alex's or the first time that
they are compressing there's so many
behind-the-scenes stories that we
probably you know weren't exposed to if
I said you can shoot hoops with Jordan l
or President Obama President Obama yeah
yeah it would be cool if she would like
to yeah but it's just shooting with Mike
that's not a big deal you want to be
playing against Mike
President Obama you would like to shoot
hoops with him because you're not
allowed to play tough defense on him
right you can't you can't pressure no no
let's like today's NBA you're not
allowed to put your hands on anybody how
do you think you would have done against
the bad boys but let's say you were
going against Detroit I think I would
have said all right because of the way I
play I think Mike ain't translates to a
lot this
I don't think certain players skill sets
like Steph Curry I mean those are those
are guys who you know they have a skill
at bball had be quickest shot shot
credibility being able to shoot from far
out I think I would have said it just
fine because of my size and ability to
just create obviously it's different it
would have been different but I think I
would have been alright just don't go to
the hoop though CJ I play I shoot good
luck in trying to get your game your
jumper to look like mine you got a
little bit of time before you have to
get back but the pull-up podcast
available on Apple and the podcast
Spotify wherever else you can get your
podcast great to check in with you CJ
thanks for joining us
no problem thanks for having me that's
CJ McCollum